why was it so important for you guys to
do this
for me um one i
i was shocked at how little i did know
about the suffrage movement
and anything that can encourage more
people
to get registered and get out to vote
and and and understand the importance of
it
you know voting has a direct
relationship
of you know to what's going to go on at
your job
in your supermarket and you know in your
your towns and your restaurants and all
that that
made me say okay i don't like certain
things i
might want to have a say in it and
rosario you talked about your
grandmother
being your influence yeah she was
born and raised in puerto rico and um
and as
i say in the podcast you know she rares
me with the understanding that just
because she spoke with an accent didn't
mean she think
that she would think with one and that
she had um
you know that she had a voice even
though she represented
a marginalized person according to you
know what she represented a paper you
know she was a mother of five
single mother my her daughter um had a
me at a you know out of wedlock as a
teenager
you know so you know we fell into the
statistics of people that so often are
marginalized
and what i loved about this podcast in
particular
was that it was starting to show the
history of how women had been voting
long before
the 19th amendment was ratified and that
there were a lot of women of color
who were still denied that right even
after it was
and i think this podcast helps to
elaborate just how many more people
are part of a history that has made it
possible for us to have the rights that
we have today
and that we have to stop marginalizing
them and discounting them from the story
you